Він тепер частий гість на німецькому телебаченні.
Бути жорстким критиком мусульман,
а потім прийняти іслам - доволі незвичний крок
для німецького політика. Та ще й
із правопопулістської партії.
Я точно знаю, чого хочу і до чого йду.
48-річного Артура Ваґнера припудрюють
перед ефіром на Deutsche Welle. Так яке ж його
справжнє обличчя? У землі Бранденбург,
що оточує Берлін, він був однією з ключових фігур
партії "Альтернатива для Німеччини", яка стверджує,
що країні загрожує ісламізація, і грає на страхах
виборців. Артур активно відстоював позиції
своєї партії і раптом вирішив сам стати
мусульманином і навіть ім'я змінити - на Ахмад.
Я взагалі хотів протягом 5 років вивчати іслам в Уфі,
а потім у своїй партії про це сказати. Я хотів
5 років спокою. Зараз у мене все по-іншому.
Артур, він же Ахмад, родом з Росії. Виріс на Уралі.
Рішення перейти в іншу віру він пояснює, зокрема,
тим, що християнська церква, за його словами,
стала терпимо ставитися до одностатевих шлюбів.
Артур залишив керівні посади в партії
"Альтернатива для Німеччини", але поки
залишається в її лавах. Каже, якщо скажуть піти,
піде.
У мене є дуже серйозні люди, які мене підтримали,
буквально на днях сказали: ти тримаєшся добре,
ти серйозна людина. А в принципі серед моїх
базових членів партії радості дуже мало.
Люди лаються.
За словами Артура, він знайшов в ісламі
всі відповіді на свої питання і присвячує себе
налагодженню звязків з мусульманським бізнесом.
Артур впевнений, що в найближчі 10 років
ставлення до ісламу в Німеччині зміниться, а те,
що зараз відбувається - це штучне нагнітання.
Втім, зовсім недавно він критикував владу ФРН
за нібито "насильницьку ісламізацію Німеччини".